discussions we don't have a utopian
vision we have a set of ideas that we
think are important too
those ideas largely have to do with
sustainability of cities the ability of
cities to overtime remain you know in
balance with the resource streams that
are available to them and they have to
do with they have to do with social
justice and equity the fundamental
conditions of satisfactory citizenship
these are the sorts of things that
concern us these are classic urban
planning and urban design issues they
just get redefined when you start to
think of them in the context of the
intelligent City so to be very specific
about that we've been looking at
reinvention of mobility systems for
example reinvention of transportation
because that's where you can get
enormous pay off the the automobile as
we know it has been around for about a
hundred years it's one of the most
successful inventions of all time that
in my view it's thoroughly obsolete at
this point and so by rethinking the
fundamentally rethinking the automobile
thinking of it as a robot on four wheels
essentially something that communica
munich ate with other intelligent
devices that can operate in a
coordinated way you can really start to
fundamentally rethink of an urban
personal mobility that's one example
if you think of the think of an
automobile think of firstly it weighs at
least 20 times the weight of the of the
rider that's crazy
it's just crazy it doesn't need to do
that or look at the footprint of it look
at the footprint this chair - that I'm
sitting in takes up look at the
footprint of an automobile and see how
large that footprint is the automobile
sits around - occupying that footprint
most of the time doing nothing most
automobiles spend about 80% of their
time just sitting around doing doing
nothing their gasoline-powered they they
go at very high speed which in fact
under urban conditions you don't need
this high-speed generate enormous safety
requirements and so on so now you can
incrementally tweak the automobile you
can make the you know the powertrain
more efficient and you can enhance
safety and all of these sorts of things
they're very worthwhile but what we are
concerned about is stepping right back
and say can you fundamentally rethink
the whole idea can you really begin to
think of urban personal mobility in
totally different terms that are
fundamentally more sustainable
fundamentally more equitable how
fundamentally better for the planet
that's what we're trying to do so we're
not working within the framework I mean
incremental tweaking but we're working
within the framework of fundamental
reinvention
well so the way that we work always is
by trying to identify the fundamental
underlying design assumptions that
everybody takes as given and
challengeable when you think about
solving these problems and we try and
challenge those assumptions so for
example everybody thinks an automobile
needs an engine well ultimately little
doesn't necessarily need an engine what
we do is shift electric motors into the
wheels of our automobiles and so we have
a completely different kind of thing
where we have four independent
intelligent wheels rather than a you
know a traditional internal combustion
engine and powertrain and so on so we do
that and then we try to make products
and systems with solutions to the
problems that we're trying to solve that
are not only good technical solutions
but engage people's imagination and
engage people's desire even automobile
is not just a way of getting around it's
a it's an expression of yourself just as
much as your clothing is your
representation in public it's an
intensely emotional thing your
relationship to your automobile so so
what we try to do is make designs that
are intensely appealing not only at a
technical level but also at a
fundamental emotional and human level I
don't think you can see succeed without
that
um if you look at urban personal
mobility there are several components to
the system so what one component is the
vehicle what what's the vehicle like is
an automobile is it a bicycle is that a
scooter is it some other kind of device
and so part of what we've been doing is
reinventing the vehicle so looking at
small lightweight electric automobiles
and other kinds of vehicles as well
another component of the system is the
the energy supply system how do you get
energy to these things and so
traditional way of doing this is
distribute gasoline around the city what
we've been looking at of course is
electrical electrical recharging
infrastructure a third part of it is how
do you gain access to vehicles when and
where you need them and what do you do
with them when you're not using them and
these were enormous problems man our
cities are choked with parking occupies
an enormous amount of space that could
be put to much better use much more
human and effective use for other
purposes it's not always easy to get
access to the vehicle that you need to
go somewhere you know you have to walk a
long way often to get talking or you
can't get a cab and all all of these
kinds of things so in response to this
this this last issue that I've mentioned
this issue of how do you do how do you
get access to vehicles and where do you
put them we've developed this concept we
call mobility on demand
it's really in principle a very simple
idea but a very profound difference from
the way we do it with private
automobiles that the idea is you have
stacks of vehicles located around the
city at conveniently spaced locations
when you want to go somewhere you simply
walk to a nearby stack pick up a vehicle
drive up to a stack drop-off point near
where you want to go and drop it off
that's one way rental and the total time
for the trip is the time to walk to a
pickup point do the train
action of picking up the vehicle
actually travel to the drop-off point
and then walk to your you know your
final destination from there we can
demonstrate that we get with this sort
of system we can get much better
door-to-door times and under you know
realistic conditions very often than you
can get with the private automobile
let's suppose that advantage of the
private automobile it's there when and
where you need it this is something of a
myth actually cuz you have to get dig it
out of parking and you may then you
don't have a parking space and so on so
so we get great door-to-door times we
believe out of this our simulation
suggests this to us
we get very high utilization rate out of
the vehicles in this sort of system so
vehicles are not sitting around doing
nothing and we occupy a minimal amount
of urban real estate to do this so it's
a system that has a tremendous number of
advantages if you can really make it
work now
fundamental technical issue with
mobility on demand systems is how do you
keep the system balanced because if you
if you just think about of this this in
very rough intuitive terms you can
imagine easily that after a while so if
all your vehicles are over here but all
the demanders are over here so how do
you you know how do you how do you keep
the system balanced and there are
various ways to think about the the way
that we do it and I think it's a very
innovative way of doing it is with
dynamic price incentives so on-the-fly
we create price incentives to return
vehicles to locations that are not
crowded that need vehicles and we create
some disincentives to you know return
them to locations that you know already
have plenty of vehicles and similarly
with pickup we make it cheap we make it
a bargain to pickup vehicles at
locations where vehicles are plentiful
and we make it a bit more expensive to
pickup vehicles where where they're
scarce so there is elasticity in the
demand for mobility and we have a
certain amount of choice about when we
make trips and exactly where we make
trips sometimes to
so we take advantage of this elast
easily we put the we put the price
incentives in there and I think we can
shows that we can very effectively
balance this kind of system using price
incentives
you know the nearest thing to
large-scale mobility on-demand systems
that exist are these European back
sharing systems that do operate in
exactly the way I described there
they're not electrical systems and
they're not automobiles but they do
operate we you know you pick up a
bicycle righted where you want to go and
drop it off and they do have significant
problems with system balancing they
really have not solved that problem very
effectively so you do find in those
systems sometimes you come to a pickup
point and was no bicycle there or you
come to drop-off is even more
frustrating come to drop-off and there's
no way to drop the back off and this is
really annoying then you have to ride
off somewhere into the distance to
actually talk you back you get a bus
back to where you need you know
obviously extremely frustrating so they
have that problem and then they have
mostly the way they do system balancing
ears by picking up bicycles and throwing
them on trucks and moving them back to
where they need to go at least I think
this is the way they do it this is what
it looks like I haven't studied it
studied it carefully so those systems
suffer from not having a sophisticated
effective solution to system balancing
now this is a prime example of why you
need intelligence and you know the whole
smart cities idea of intelligences the
key I think to sustainability and social
equity in cities in the future because
the dynamic pricing kind of structure
that I'm talk talking about that I
talked about a moment ago depends on
electronically keeping track of where
the vehicles are having sophisticated
information processing so you
dynamically adjust the prices I'm
running an optimization algorithm in
many ways it's it's sort of something
like let's say Google which is you know
big complex system that in the end
depends on some sophisticated algorithms
to deliver to people or services they
need and this is very similar so so
mostly the way people have tended to
think in the past about mobility is it's
a matter of providing the hardware and
providing access to the vehicles and you
know physically moving
all around I would argue that in the
future it's much more about
sophisticated management algorithms and
making the best use of the resources
that you have and through information
technology
one of the problems in transforming any
kind of large-scale system is what I
like to think of as let's call it
horseless carriage thinking and even the
terms sort of suggest to you what I'm
talking about here so when the horseless
carriage replaced the horse and carriage
essentially it was a kind of
substitution to take out the horse and
put in the internal combustion engine
and right and and and then the way
people are intended to talk to think
about electric automobiles as you take
out the internal combustion engine and
you stick in a hybrid powertrain or you
stick in a battery electric system I
think you have to step back and say no
the real potential is to fundamentally
rethink the way things work so part of
the fundamental rethinking that I think
is necessary with electric vehicles is
to get away from the old idea that you
fill a vehicle up with a fairly large
amount of energy and drive it around for
quite a long time and then fill it up
again
which is the gas station model right and
so people have taken that over into
thinking about batteries right to charge
up the batteries and you drive around
for a long time and then you you charge
them up again our view is quite
different our view is that and I sort of
I'm going to glide over some fairly
complex technical issues here the basic
idea is recharge every time you park so
think of parking spaces as being like
the hold of your electric toothbrush you
know you drop your electric toothbrush
back in the holder automatically
recharges and you never think about
charging the toothbrush and it's never
without charge because whenever you're
not using it it's just picking up charge
so imagine a kind of system where you
have lightweight electric vehicles
relatively small battery capacity and
then picking up charge wherever they
park so that is interesting user model
you can begin to understand from a
user's point of view how that can work
you never have to worry about filling up
your car right never go to the gas
station never plug it in and never do
any of these things from the point of
view of
ability and the electric grid it has a
whole other set of advantages because if
you do this you throw a large amount of
battery storage capacity into the
electric grid now part of the problem
with electric grids is they don't have a
lot of storage capacity usually they
don't have any storage capacity which
means you have a problem of peak loading
and once again it's a balancing problem
you have to have to you have to size the
grid to deal with that hot summer day
when everybody is you know turn their
air conditioning on that you know the
rest of the time you have over capacity
if you size it for that this is
oversimplifying a complex issue then you
get the idea and then there's also a
problem with intermittency clean power
sources like solar and wind particularly
don't necessarily supply electricity
when you need it the wind doesn't
necessarily blow when you want the
electricity the Sun doesn't necessarily
shine but if you have storage capacity
in the grid and then you set it up so
that automobiles can buy and sell
electricity from their battery storage
they become little energy traders
essentially this gives you a mechanism
for for balancing for balancing the
electrical grid and for making clean
that intermittent power source is much
more cost-effective so you see with with
all of these issues I think you have to
look at them from multiple points of
view simultaneously so from one point of
view the strategy of electric charging
we're looking at is just convenience for
the convenience of the user from another
point of view it's a strategy for making
the grid much more much more friendly to
clean clean green electric sources you
always want to look for these win wins
in design
any large-scale effective solution to
problems of mobility for example I think
does depend on developing very effective
public-private partnerships and aligning
goals aligning objectives I'm getting
everybody moving in the same direction
this is a gigantic challenge this this
is one of the the major challenges in in
doing all of this and the current
players are not used to this the for
example Detroit is not used to working
with local government in order to
implement you know solutions to mobility
issues the the electrical grid people
are certainly not used to working with
automobile companies and so on so I
think one of you know we need good
technical solutions to what we need to
do as I discussed before we need these
highly desirable products and systems
that people are actually going to want
to use then too but then the other
component is this component of aligning
goals building coalitions getting
everybody moving at least enough people
moving in the same direction to
accomplish the large-scale
transformations which are very very
difficult
I think part of this is just accidental
you know often these things happen some
entrepreneur gets an idea and they
haven't have a particular context and
that's where it happened so it's a part
of it's just accident and circumstance
part of a TD illogical I think I think
there is a a greater readiness in in
Europe to deal with some public
solutions rather than private solutions
to to some of these issues and then
there are just circumstantial things
that make it easier to do in particular
context in American cities a kind of
difficult contexts to work in
politically complex there are a lot of
different interest groups it takes a
mint political skill to get anything
done at all you think of the difficulty
that Mayor Bloomberg had for example
trying to get congestion pricing done in
Manhattan he failed ultimately he didn't
succeed in doing this so I think the
difficulty of doing it in American urban
context is often you know a big barrier
in Paris there's a system is very
powerful mayor and it was possible for
actually an outdoor advertising company
to go to the mayor and say here's a deal
for you you know we can supply this
mobility on demand bicycle based
mobility under Maine system if you'll
give us the real estate in the city that
we need to do this and the mayor is
powerful enough to do this imagine
trying to do this in New York great this
is very much more of a top-down kind of
system and then the payoff there's it's
an advertising model essentially what
the provider got there was advertising
space in the city of Paris so it's a
particular set of circumstances where
kind of the opportunities all lined up
and made it possible now the lesson I
draw from that is not the lessons you
throw up your hands and so it's
impossible in the United States the
lesson I draw is you have to figure out
the particular ways to
you know I line up the various different
interests and create the opportunity
that you you want now there are some
other issues in this too I think you
know a city like New York is
unbelievably complex just to operating I
wouldn't I wouldn't start with New York
that's right
there are take a city like Singapore for
example it's much more a kind of
top-down context for getting things
implemented and then you know pretty
very efficient sort of technocratic and
a framework for getting things done so
you know so there are contexts where
it's easier to get things done than
other contexts now I have great belief
in democratic complexity in the
representation of you know different
interest groups and so on that it does
make it slower sometimes to get things
done in this sort of context
yeah we believe very strongly in cross
disciplinary collaboration to deal with
these large-scale issues because the the
problems have no respect for traditional
disciplinary boundaries and ISO so
dealing with mobility on demand systems
for example you know we have to design
electric vehicles so there's a
mechanical engineering and product
design issue there's a there's an issue
of electrical systems there's an issue
of information systems there's an issue
of urban real estate and urban design
there's an issue of the you know the
economics and business models of these
systems there's an issue of how you do
the the software that does the
optimization of the systems and so so
this you know sprawls in an incredibly
messy way across a lot of traditional
disciplinary boundaries that's exactly
where we love to work I mean that's just
exactly where we think we can make our
major contribution but that is different
from the traditional disciplinary
organization of universities where you
know the mechanical engineering
department does mechanical engineering
and the urban planners do urban planning
and so on so we very explicitly you know
put forward an alternative model and
then I think the the other thing that we
do that I think is very important is we
collaborate very very closely with
industry and it's not just a matter of
industry providing funding but it's
really engaging the expertise that
industry brings to the table it's very
much an intellectual a collaboration so
you know our city car project we
collaborate very closely with General
Motors and despite the popular
perception right now they do know a lot
about building automobiles you know I
have enormous respect for the people we
work with in MGM we've worked with city
governments we work with we're working
right now with Schneider Electric in
looking at the you know that the the the
large scale electrical systems and so on
and so I think this is absolutely
necessary I think this is very very
important and I say this is very much as
our role and in being able to
lay out some version of a comprehensive
vision that integrates the different
perspectives and different disciplinary
viewpoints very challenging very
difficult way to work enough so it's
much easier just to say well this is my
area of expertise and I'll stay within
it that we we make a major point of
operating in this way and I think it's
absolutely essential
now there's no magical solution because
you know urban traffic congestion arises
from in fact a lot of people want to be
in the same place at the same time often
I'd like a Red Sox game or something
like it's gonna get congested around
there that's just them just just just
the way it goes and so there's no magic
you know in all of this but they're a
bunch of things that you can do firstly
our cars a much smaller footprint than
traditional automobiles secondly they
occupy much less parking space
thirdly they're managed and this is
actually more important they're managed
in a more sophisticated way so you get
high utilization rates you make them
available exactly where they need to be
available and then get them out of the
way and then the other thing is if you
think of traffic flow the way you get
throughput the way you really move a lot
of people quickly through a city is not
through high speed this is where I
having a cars guys 120 miles an hour
useless in a city what what really
matters is keeping a uniform speed of if
you can keep steady pace of movement you
can get an enormous throughput the way
you keep the steady pace of movement is
by electronic coordination of traffic
streams so there's not a lot of stop and
start and acceleration and deceleration
but you smooth it all out and that
that's really the key thing
a lot of our thinking has to do with
creating sort of markets for the
resources that you need for urban
mobility that are kind of transparent
where there's plenty of information in
the market we know what you're doing and
where price incentives enable the sort
of management of the system so one
example of that is you know congestion
pricing streets so when one way to do
there's a typical way to do this that
gets thought about these days is very
crude you put a congestion area around
Manhattan and charge people ten dollars
or something if they cross the
congestion ring if you put more
information technology into it you can
begin to think of things like you get
you monitor traffic congestion on a
block by block level of granularity and
then you adjust prices in real time then
the more congestion the block you you
know the more it cost you to drive down
and then you can organize an autumn a
GPS navigation system to do things like
take me the cheapest way to where I need
to go subject to a time constraint or
take me the fastest way subject to a
cost constraint and this I think in the
end gives more you know rational
allocation of resources makes a more
transparent system all of these kinds of
things and another example of this is
with parking so right now parking is a
terrible market correct its parking
costs a lot prices are fixed typically
how do you connect buyers to sell lows
you drive around randomly looking for a
parking space right this is not great
but imagine a system where the
automobile navigation system knows where
the parking spaces are in near where you
want to park they're dynamically priced
and you do an eBay style auction
essentially right so you say do your
automobile
all right I'm desperate I've got a
mentalist appointment in ten minutes I
can't be late just find me a parking
space now pay pretty much anything just
bid high right and in it can do that or
I'm a poor student
right and I don't mind if I walk for 15
minutes just get me a bag and so bid low
and so you can do that kind of thing and
then we've already talked about mobility
on-demand we're getting access to
vehicles the the pricing of that can
vary essentially depending on demand
that the higher the demand the more you
have to pay that so so I think we are
going to see a great deal more of
systems in which there's sort of much
more sophisticated pricing and much more
sophisticated understanding both by the
providers of mobility resources and by
the consumers and mobility resources
what it's costing and how you want to
allocate your resources right now it's
very difficult to be rational about
moving around the city so we want to
make it possible for people to be more
rational
well I think it has a lot to do with
political will and capacity to sort of
build desire to do something like this
so some cities can do that some can't I
think there is a complementarity to mass
transit one of the best uses and
mobility on-demand systems is to solve
what I like to call the last kilometer
problem or the last mile problem with
you know a subway system for example is
extremely efficient getting you from one
subway station to another subway station
but the subway station where you start
has never where you really want to start
your journey in the subway station where
your finish has never really went where
you want to end up mobility on-demand
system can solve that last mile problem
it can get you to the subway station and
then you can go you know very
efficiently point-to-point using the
subway system and then at the other end
out in the suburbs for example you can
you can pick up a city car and mobility
on-demand system go to where you want to
go so I think there is an advantage in
having a highly evolved public transit
system that you can develop a synergy
with I think this is important and then
some of it has to do with what kind of
physical opportunities exist to build
the system too so we've looked at a
number of cities we look for example at
Taipei in a lot of detail we discovered
that active this is obvious if you go to
Taipei it has the highest density of
convenience stores in the world there
are 7-elevens everywhere in taipei so an
attractive strategy in taipei is to say
put mobility andaman pick-up and
drop-off points outside convenience
stores where the space for the real
estate that almost automatically in in
the right locations there's a business
synergy and so on so that's the
particular opportunity that exists in in
taipei take another city we've looked at
as Florence which couldn't be more
different from Taipei and the historic
urban texture of Florence is built
around the piazzas that are related to
the churches and the old parish
that kind of thing and so the strategy
there that we pursued as a strategy of
putting mobility on demand pick-up and
drop-off points in the Piazza's getting
traditional automobile parking out of
the piazzas giving the piazzas back to
the people of the social centers and so
on so I think there's no what what I'm
getting at is no general answer here
there are a lot of conditions that may
make a city suitable or not suitable for
mobility on demand systems no simple
formula I think it takes imagination and
design skill and just looking at a
particular city and say how would we do
it in this particular city what are the
opportunities what are the constraints
what's the what's the best way to do
this technological barriers are not
great so I think we can build the right
kinds of automobiles within a couple of
years and I don't think that's a long
timeline I think the the regulatory
issues and the political consensus
building issues are potentially the you
know the long timeline and that could
take many years I think this the cities
that are likely to be competitive and
they're likely to win in doing these
sorts of things the ones that are able
to cut through all of that kind of stuff
and move you know quickly and
effectively hard to say which ones
they'll they could be a place like
Singapore for example which has a
history of being able to do things like
this
no no you I think you have to
distinguish between what I'll call
incremental R&D which can be very
focused you know you can say that we
need to improve the efficiency of this
system whatever it is about ten percent
or something and you can focus a bunch
of resources on doing that and be with a
fairly high probability of success you
know get that payoff but the really big
fundamental transformations are
fundamentally unpredictable and that's
the very definition of a creative
disruptive transformation in fact and
those things where the big payoff comes
from so the the internet for example
came out of nowhere and I've been around
long enough and I was around the
beginning of the internet that I
remember it personally so I can attest
right that it came nobody knew and what
to do with this it came out of some
esoteric backroom research that nobody
thought had any huge practical
implication whatsoever forty years later
it is about 40 years now it's
transformed the world now to completely
transform the world so I think the most
effective economic thing that you can do
and that's uncertain you know it's risky
and uncertain that you have to preserve
the capacity for truly innovative
unpredictable undirected research you
know it's just just what you have to do
if you want the really big payoffs and
this drives people crazy because they
want predictability but if you think
about the fundamental contradiction
between the idea of making a fundamental
creative innovation and being totally
predictable right it was totally
predictable anybody could do it so no I
think the place like MIT and I think a
place like the Media Lab particularly is
very much dedicated to that idea that we
investigate all kinds of crazy things
and frankly most of them fail or at
least in the short term they don't go
anywhere
but every now and again one of them pays
off really big time and really
transforms things and I think you have
to do that it's a way to look at it it's
like any other kind of investment you
know portfolio of investments know
everything about investing research and
development money you you you you you
you want to pursue some straightforward
sure things that need to get done but
you don't want to neglect the the big
transformative things that's very very
short-sighted
transportation
specifically I think they're they they
have to do I think mostly with various
aspects of what we've already talked
about so I think we are going to see
some big breakthroughs in light weight
efficient electric vehicles over the
next few years a very difficult to
predict exactly how that's going to go
but it's I think a very certain
prediction that we're going to see a lot
of development in that area so that's
one thing I think we're going to see
some very surprising things in
large-scale intelligent clean energy
systems and they've talked about some of
the sorts of things that can maybe
happen there and then I think you know
rethinking the whole concept of mobility
with things like mobility on demand
systems as another big thing here's the
way I'd look at it if you'd look at the
sustainability challenges that cities
face over the next 20 years 30 years
they're formidable and everybody knows
this incremental advances are not going
to get us to where we need to be I mean
incrementally improving the efficiency
and cleanliness of the power trains of
automobiles and all these sorts of
things
they're very worthwhile and we shouldn't
stop pursuing them they're not going to
get us to where we need to be so we need
in parallel to that I have this
imaginative search for the big
transformative changes that are really
reading to be real game changers that
are really going to redefine redefine
the whole thing but that's what we're
looking for in the work that we're doing
here there's an appropriate role for us
I mean we're not industry we were
University Research Group we have of
certain sorts of privileges and freedoms
and we ought to take advantage of that
too
go for these for the what I think I was
the big player